oh hi you know what's even more fun than
running from zombies not having to run
from zombies and resident evil the
darkside chronicles for the Wii you
don't have to actually move or anything
it just does all the running from
zombies for you you just sit back on
your couch hold your remote and blow
their brains out Cherie where are you
yes yes it's another on-rails shooter
for the Wii I feel your pain we owners
you already have stacks of first-person
shooters that move around by themselves
but the darkside chronicles is a more
polished experience there's a really
cool shaky horror film camera there's a
lot more of those oh my god behind you
kind of moments and the cooperative play
is more than just adding another cursor
to the screen you'll be helping out your
partner and you'll have to cooperate by
hitting the right buttons at the same
time a lot of really cool stuff
the first level we saw is set during the
events of Resident Evil 2 featuring leon
kennedy and claire redfield meeting up
with another familiar face I'm Leon this
is Claire and you are eight a wall wait
hey hold up what is it all right yes
look I know we don't know each other but
we're the only survivors left you need
to work together
we need to get out of here the next
level was set in the old Ashford mansion
from the dreamcast game resident evil
code veronica that wacky schizophrenic
crossdresser alfred Ashford is added
again sending you into a poorly designed
quote-unquote filled room full of crazy
pratts
so besides getting to revisit all of
your favorite levels from previous
resident evil games darkside chronicles
will also have new stories set in South
America you're going to be able to play
it for yourself on November 17